careful careful careful
why would you ask
[Music]
for first week Feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Bob Odenkirk
he's an actor and writer whose resume
includes everything from the pioneering
sketch comedy series Mr show to Breaking
Bad and an acclaimed performance as
Jimmy Mcgill and Better Call Saul you
can also catch him starring in AMC's
brand new comedy drama lucky Hank which
is set to premiere on March 19th Bob
Odenkirk welcome to the show Hi how are
you I'm doing great I'm doing great how
are you especially around a little tired
yeah yeah I do see the value of like
when there's kind of an intense spice
mixed in with flavors it kind of is an
awesome thing you know but I've never
understood you know like the pure hot
[__] that just like blows your brain out
like I don't get what you're getting
from that but you know what it makes
good TV it makes good TV oh I guess so
I've heard such things such a good
things about the show and I know that
you've done great interviews
I don't particularly see the connection
there's a sense that the person is
disarmed a bit because they're
distracted by the heat but I think I'm
perfectly capable of talking without
having a part of my body injured
okay
read the whole wing
a bite usually does the trick
but I'll go wherever you go today well
this is just really good there we go
yeah this is not there's a big hint of
heat at the end it's just damn good
there we go
[Music]
that's really good
wow
up to a hot start there we go again get
a round of applause yeah there we go
so in your latest project lucky Hank you
play an English department chair who
describes the college he works at as
mediocrity's capital yeah and I was
immediately hooked by the first scene
when your character begrudgingly offers
harsh feedback to a student's essay was
playing a cantankerous English professor
at all cathartic for you considering how
much of your career you've spent
obsessing over the written word I would
um it was it wasn't so much the
cantankerous part that was cathartic
uh after playing Saul Goodman for so
long
this guy is sort of fundamentally
different than Saul because he is
connected to people in his world he
loves them they love him
not to mention there's no drugs there's
no guns there's no cartel there's no
zombies there
is there's genre peace
this uh lucky Hank is closest to like an
Alexander Payne film it's like equal
parts comedy drama
thank you
I don't eat a lot of wings in my life
look at you though could have fooled me
well going in now that
is um
yeah
this is a little more wanting to be hot
but it's still not right it's flavorful
yeah
nothing beats this one there we go
so like you I'm a product of the Chicago
suburbs and a broadcasting major in what
ways do you think your affection for
comedy was shaped by watching stations
like WGN and channel 11 PBS well
definitely Channel 11 with Monty Python
Dave Allen at large
uh The Two Ronnies python was the one
that made me go wait what is this
they're making fun of everything yeah
and they're being hard but it's silly as
hell
and then you've got Terry gilliam's
absurdity which kind of takes you a step
back and makes you go like come on it's
just uh it's cartoons it's nothing but
it's really gotta [__] You by yeah at
the core of it which I loved yeah did
you have a favorite Chicagoland Regional
TV commercial you know it doesn't matter
yeah what's his face we've made fun of
it on Mr Show
Ford
come on you don't remember this maybe
it's just past mine because like I am a
good old summer time hi Airy shmirler
here you're a singing Ford dealer this
week we have
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm not scared
so long huh
yeah
okay
a little bit of a higher level but
manageable I'm seeing yeah no there we
go Bob yeah
crushing it a little hot hotter
definitely sticking around a little
longer I'll leave it a little bit of a
trail behind
so in 1989 the Chicago Tribune described
your one-man show half my face as a
clown is determinately and truly silly
and satisfyingly so what can a one-man
show do or accomplish that other genres
can't
group together and finding a stage two
show is not always so easy so stand-up
comedy boomed when I moved to Chicago it
had this crazy Heyday that was insane
yeah insane and there were 14 comedy
clubs in Chicago at one point
and I had a thought that my stuff could
live in that world it was almost like
sketch comedy done by one person
there was uh oh there was an improv
piece
that I really loved to do I go hey
everybody I'm going to do some improv we
do this game it's called you know pick a
hat and there's got a box full of hats
I'm gonna just pick one out I don't know
what it'll be but whatever it is I will
do a character based on that so I pull
out a hat it's a baseball cap and I I
think and start playing baseball hey
Bata hey there you know uh back off the
plate better you know I yeah give it to
him hot come on I throw the Hat away I
reach in and I pull out it's the same
baseball cap and now I'm like uh hey hey
hey hey hey better here comes the heat
you know I'm the catcher now so now he's
the catcher and then another hat and now
it's another baseball cap
and then he's the shortstop but if he's
like hey better come on throw some meat
I'm the shortstop and uh and then uh
puts that way he reaches in
it's a fireman's helmet
and he throws it away
[__] yeah I don't remember the ending
but uh that was really fun
so you know
um
yeah that's what it was I love that walk
down memory lane all right Bobby ready
to move on here to Sauce number four
Calientes
yep parody do you cut this show up or do
you make us make people [__] watch me
12 wings no no wait we're very kind in
the edit
[Music]
now does milk really help so I guess
kind of but what I've found is once
you're in it you're just in it you know
what I mean like you're just in the
tidal wave you just have to hold on to
the board you know there's nothing that
nothing's gonna change it it's not
nothing's gonna bring you back to Earth
so you've shared a stage at the Second
City theater with Chris Farley how early
on did you recognize his potential as a
performer when I got within 100 feet for
the first time yeah Chris is this guy
you know Jack Black Chris Farley these
are people who when people I I love it
when people go that guy's got something
they're like yeah really you think you
know I mean who [__] can't tell that
he's the [__]
I love Chris and then the motivational
speaker the sketch I wrote for him that
did so well and we had done an
improvisation
and we were all playing teachers of a
school and it was like a don't don't do
drugs Rally or whatever we were talking
to the students and he did his coach
character and uh it was Matt Foley he
might even use the name Matt Foley it
didn't have a story van down by the
river it wasn't a motivational speaker
but you know he uh you know was going
come on you guys and it it stuck in my
head as it would anyone and I went home
that night and I wrote that sketch and
I've written hundreds of sketches of my
life
and I wrote it exactly the way it's done
although Robert Smiggle added the CR
breaking the table we didn't do that at
Second City but everything else is
exactly the way I wrote it that night in
my little apartment in Chicago and
brought it into Chris and said here's a
sketch you can do that character you did
and uh
and and my daughter once asked me what
was the most fun you had in Showbiz and
I said
I did this sketch with Chris Farley I
played the dad in the sketch and we did
it seven times a week at at Second City
every time I did that was the most fun I
had in Show Business
[Music]
I'm waiting until we get to that place
where it's just a two by four to the
mouth
[Music]
um that is not unpleasant and it's it is
hot yep we're not fooling around now
right it's getting better it has flavor
still exactly like a nice spicy curry
almost yeah
there we go Bob you're doing great
you're doing great
should I do it
that's one thing about me I show up
we got Seth Meyers this question but I'm
curious your perspective is someone who
understands sketch comedy on a technical
level do you ever feel like there's a
tension between what writers think is
funny and what audiences think is funny
like is there a comedy corollary to like
an Eminem verse that's so obsessed with
the mechanics of rapping that people
listening to it can't even tell if it's
good or not
in Mr show I can point to hunger strike
and
one of my favorites of all time the
story of Everest where he keeps knocking
over the Thimbles now a lot of people
absolutely love the story of Everest
it's their favorite sketch but there are
people who hate it
and hunger strike is a great one that
I think is one of the best things we
wrote it's David Cross as a Eastern
Mystic
uh who's been on a hunger strike and
he's going to make a speech he's been on
hunger strike for you know 40 days and
he's supposed to talk about his people
and and they're getting their freedom
and all he can talk about is food
this is [__] genius and it's so funny
but some people hate it
when you do that thing where you repeat
the joke and you grind it into the
ground that can be so funny to comedy
writers a lot has to do with where
something is when you see it
I think sometimes performers don't
understand that they don't think about
that because
you take that same audience you put them
in a stand-up club and they think I need
to get this one thing it better be that
and then you walk them across the street
into a theater on the same night and
they their brains can open up to all
kinds of other things that you could do
and so the venue matters a lot anyway
Theory I have a lot of theory I got a
lot of theory in me
[Music]
a guy who looks like Debbie cross on the
cover
yeah yeah honestly I don't think it's
hotter I think he [__] up man
go ahead rearrange
shifting gears over here
so I think you're an inspiration to
anyone who wants to evolve their career
not the least of which the entertainment
people who have lauded your ability to
span everything from Best in Class TV
drama to absurdist Comedy looking back
at your career so far what do you see as
the value of a bomb
bravery that you first a sense that
but I'm not different
you may not like that movie I did and
you're maybe right
I think sometimes people don't
understand
how much a filmmaker or actor maybe
agrees with your appraisal of their work
right you you know there's a review and
it's this isn't good and that isn't good
and the actor or some of them me
or the director oftentimes me is like oh
you're right
you know but that you can't kind of show
that face you have to
you have to support all the people who
made the project and we're not on a limb
with you I almost pursue failure
sometimes because if you get afraid of
that you're [__]
again I would I would would and have go
ahead and look at my resume
you'll be able to pick them out
done projects that were really wobbly
like did you think that was going to
work
and just you know no I didn't
all right Bobby you're ready to move on
here to Sauce number seven yeah this is
the dreams of calypso a little step up
here
going in
[Music]
I'm trying not to read the labels
because they're all like ah
[Music]
I'm very impressed Bobby's walked in
here being like I'm not really a hot
sauce guy
I'm definitely not it's not bad it's got
flavors you are though there's still
flavor here going on dreams of calypso
it's a beautiful label
in an interview with vanity fairy said
you don't like how much resentment
drives Jimmy's actions with that in mind
what were your thoughts on Jimmy's
treatment of Howard
yeah I don't like it
very upsetting very unnerving to play a
guy
you know this goes to playing people who
have serious you know issues which are
the only kind of people they write
because that's fun to watch
and I remember reading about Brian
playing Walter White and I remember
reading about Gandolfini playing Tony
Soprano and the frustrations that they
felt with the challenge of just staying
in that guy's head and I would be like
well come on it's acting
I mean how how hard can that be and then
I got to do something and I was like oh
this is [__] hard because you're that
guy for 12 hours a day
for years
and even though it's not your real life
you know that's what you're this what
acting is sitting there going I Feel
This and like he feels that and I'm
feeling this and I resent this and I
want that and why do I want it because
[__] that guy and [__] this person and
I'm gonna get him back and you know and
you're just Conjuring up those feelings
it's exhausting
you know that they say don't hold on to
resentments and stuff and E it's true I
mean don't [__] it compartmentalize let
go of that [__] because it's just
killing you it's not gonna help you make
better choices it's going to hurt you
more than it hurts anyone you resent
all right just be careful
[Music]
it's probably hitting for you now just
like it is for me
trying to get a read
[Music]
Satan's [__]
I'm gonna join you
that sauce
not for no reason
[Music]
I know I know
so I was a big fan of your 2021 film
Nobody
a hyper violent last person standing
action film that required almost two
years to prepare for what would you say
are the characteristics of a good
Hollywood fight scene like what makes
this fight scenes and nobody works so
well
you know what I'm eating chicken wings
right now right I know
careful careful careful
why would you ask
[Music]
us I love the Jason Bourne films but
when he's fighting he's just a machine
some of them
their job is to present a tough guy and
so they're meant to be a fighting
machine that is tough and is not afraid
of anything and doesn't get hurt
so I thought well I could play a guy who
does get hurt and does feel it but in
order to do that
we have to leave the camera on your face
and leave it on you during the fight
long shot so that means you have to do
your own fighting yeah hell yeah and you
did but I thought you know if I'm gonna
do this then that means I have to do the
fighting because I want to bring this
thing into action films where I stay in
character in the middle of the fight and
I've gotten hurt I'm scared I'm not sure
I'm gonna succeed here or maybe I feel
Glee whatever it is the character's
still alive even in the middle of the
fight
so that's what I thought I could bring
to that genre and um that's why I had to
train so long
I mean that sucked I why would you buy
this
you're an idiot and why would you I'll
wear that I'll wear that that's [__]
[Laughter]
on that note are you ready to move on to
the ninth sauce whoa
that's how you do it there you go that
is how you do it Bob that is how you do
it
you're stuck
you said you're gonna give me these yes
you don't have to give me that one
you all favored
these are good
there we go there we go then some then
there's yeah
as wide as the Grand Canyon there
did you have a biggest customer pet
peeve when you were serving burgers at
debevics before your comedy career took
off well
[Music]
my biggest problem with that de bevix
and it says something about my talent as
an actor
you know uh being a waiter there you're
you're supposed to like be a smart alec
yeah and be rude
well all the waiters and waitresses
could do that and it was fun and
whatever but then when I became a waiter
I didn't really want to do it but also I
can't
because when most people go sit down
people are like oh and when I go sit
down they go what I'm sorry what he's
mean
world's smallest Sunday overrated or
underrated
oh uh no that's uh underrated you like
the world portion control
s get the world's smallest Sunday I
didn't know you knew that but you once
had the difference yeah yeah
if only what is this this is the killer
this is the last day why are you opening
it
if I said I do the show it's actually a
problem that super responsible quality
that I have right right
um it's from growing up in a family of
seven with a dad who wasn't home well
but that last dab thing there's nothing
responsible about that oh that's too
much that's that's big I would take a
walk yeah yeah okay so there's still
some on there there is
I'm not cheating
this is gonna suck right you know what I
think yeah the worst is kind of over
that's what I'll say
well there's not a shock
Ed
right
but mercifully
our dinner date with the wings of death
it's come to an end all right and we
covered your wide-ranging career from
writer's room journeyman to TV star to
action movie leading man but I know that
the Bob Odenkirk experience ultimately
it's that angsty kid walking through the
theater line streets of Old Town with a
fire in his belly and a chip on his
shoulder that's right Robin Williams
once said for me comedy starts as a spew
a kind of explosion and then you sculpt
it from there if at all it comes out of
a deeper darker side does that resonate
with you yeah
comedy is
finding the things you hate about people
and the world and having fun with that
making fun of that
and it could be a little tiny dumb thing
that you hate a thing you hate about
yourself uh
a behavior in the world that just
takes you off
and
and then turning that into uh Joy
well Mike drop and look at you Bob
Odenkirk taking on the wings of Dyson
you're not a hot sauce guy I see no milk
not a sip of milk this entire time now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you Bob this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
oh
um lucky Hank
is a new show
it's comedy drama mixed even Steven
comes on AMC March 19th
it's an amazing cast beautiful funny
funny actors in every direction so I
hope you'll give it a try and stick with
it and
in October
thing I'm proudest of in the world I
wrote a book with my kids and my
daughter did the illustrations it's
called zealot
and other important Rhymes it's poems
for kids I wrote them with my kids when
they were little we would write a poem
together a silly one and then some of
them were good and I kept them around
and then when my daughter grew up she's
an artist and she just did the drawings
for them so please watch for that if you
have anyone between three and eight in
your house or soon to be
[Applause]
you did it
thank you that was uh far more uh
entertaining and fun than I thought it
would be
[__]
[Music]
hello I'm camera guy Bill
well I'm the kind of cowboy who likes to
sausage wings but I need a brand new
flavor to make these tastes insane plus
a killing Maple that's rolling down the
line All Aboard it's Canadian time would
you look at that coming around the bend
a dash chili frizzles from smoking Ed
sauce is loose runaway Caboose hotter
than a babe on a moose or a great
northern staple try that classic
chilling Maple made with real maple
syrup making on your stirrups
Gideon
burst to face got the Tweet hey Get on
Up and Dance on your feet first and face
got the sweet heat Get on Up and Dance
on your feet sweet and refreshing to
keep your senses guessing with the tiny
apple cider tons of bucking rodeo rider
whoa
Let's Open The Honky Tonks Just Begun
get permission from your mom go to
heatness.com
[Music]
for a Great Northern State we'll try
that classic chili maple
oh
[Music]
for a great northern staple shot that
classic chili maple
[Music]
y'all come back now